thanks tony and we're joined now by dr
tom engelsby
for advice on how voters can stay
healthy and safe as they cast their
ballots
dr inglesby is the director of the
center for health security at the
johns hopkins bloomberg school of public
health good morning doctor thanks for
being with us
how concerned anthony how concerned are
you about coronavirus transmission at
polling stations
and should people feel safe voting in
person
i think if people follow simple
simple instructions take normal kind of
sensible actions
that the risk can be as little as going
to the pharmacy or going to the grocery
store but they have to think about it
ahead of time
plan ahead of time and then act in ways
that public health suggests
when they're at the at the voting voting
place what about those polling stations
where masks are not required
yeah well in every place in the country
people should be using mass when they
vote i think i mean going backwards to
what they should be doing before they
even get there
people should think about when they can
vote where there's where the
the fewest number of people will be
there and in 20 states
today the polls are still open for early
voting so i think i'd recommend going
today as opposed tomorrow there's less
density of the of the crowds
if you go tomorrow then try to vote in a
time when
most people aren't there we know that
people go to the polls
and before work or during lunch or after
after work is over so if you can go
mid-morning mid-afternoon there are less
people there
before you go you should you bring your
pen
bring if you need to plan ahead bring a
chair if you need it
bring 60 hand sanitizer or hand
sanitizer with more
percent alcohol to be safe
and look at the the sample ballot before
you go
know who you're going to vote for know
what the ballot questions are so that
when you're inside
where the risks are higher than outside
you can get in and get out quickly
so that's what i do before you go but
when you're at the poll
then you follow the things that we're
supposed to be following all along wear
a mask whether or not your state
requires it it's important for everyone
it protects your neighbor and you
and the second thing you should do is
keep your distance
when you're in line make sure that you
stay six feet away or more from others
and it doesn't matter if people are
wearing masks you still need to stay
away from them by at least six feet
yeah and then before you go into the
polls or out of the polls make sure you
use
hand sanitizer yeah i should say in in
my polling station early voting last
week
everybody was being extremely careful
and everyone was being very respectful
of each other
it was very encouraging uh so hopefully
that's being replicated around the
country
as you've heard dr fauci has has said in
recent days that
that he fears we're in for a whole lot
of hurt in the coming weeks
uh and that we could not be positioned
more poorly
what do you fear is ahead of us at this
point
yeah unfortunately with the way that the
numbers are rising on a
daily and weekly basis i think we're
headed for very high numbers of cases
more hospitalizations and higher numbers
of people dying from this disease
i think it's it's not a foregone
conclusion i think we do still have our
fate in our hands
but governors and other leaders are
going to have to change direction in
places where cases are surging
and people are going to have to change
the way that they're acting and change
their decisions in places where p
where the cases are surging we're at 100
000 we're at 100
000 cases a day you think it can go a
lot higher than that
yeah there is no set peak for this virus
this virus
is looking for people to infect that's
what it does it hasn't changed since the
very beginning
and we know that most of the country
still is susceptible to this virus it's
still vulnerable to this virus
so the thing that's going to change it
isn't the virus but it's what we decide
to do
it's whether we decide to wear masks
whether we decide to distance ourselves
to not gather in large numbers
we have to do those things ourselves to
change the course dr tom inglesby thank
you so much for being with us